it is great to be joined today by Scott
Kelly who's a retired astronaut veteran
of four space flights commanded the
International Space Station on three
expeditions also a member of the
year-long mission to the International
Space Station which we'll talk about
Scott thank you so much for talking to
me
my pleasure so where to start I mean I
think you know so many kids say I want
to be an astronaut when I grow up so I
guess a good place to start is what what
actually made you want to be an
astronaut well I'm not the typical kind
of person that became an astronaut I
wasn't the best student in school I
struggled never really did well
graduated from high school in the bottom
half of my class and then when I went to
college I was kind of having the same
experience I didn't know how to study I
couldn't pay attention eventually I'm
like barely even going to class anymore
and then one day I'm walking across the
college campus and I go into the
bookstore to buy like gum or something
not a book but I see this book on this
shelf and it's got this really cool like
red white and blue cover it's got the
cool title made me pick it up look
through it and turned out the book was
the right stuff by Tom Wolfe and I felt
like I could really relate to the
characters in this in this book I don't
know if it was because Tom was such a
great writer or you know I really did
have something in common with these guys
but I felt like they were like normal
people like me but with one exception
and they were accomplished students and
graduated from college with degrees in
science and engineering and I thought
you know I could do that that one part
maybe I could fly in the air play an
airplane in the Navy or or be a test
pilot someday or maybe even be an
astronaut so you know for me I to
summarize that I was this kid no one
would have expected to have this
privilege to do this but due to some
inspiration I found as an 18 year old I
was able to go pretty far how would you
characterize the importance of your
engineering background versus your
background in piloting right whether
it's the military test pilot etc is it
is it 50/50 what goes in to doing the
work you've done as an astronaut is it
more one versus the other well you know
as a test pilot in the military you're
really what's called an an engineering
test pilot which means you're both an
engineer and pilot of a flight vehicle
and the Space Shuttle was very much a
white test vehicle it had never even at
the end of its lifetime it had never
flown many flights so every time we
would fly it we were investigating new
things so you know I violated the Space
Shuttle I docked it with the
International Space Station I landed it
but I was also also very much you know
served in a role as a as an engineer I
would say as far as importance on the on
the space shuttle yeah my my skills as a
test pilot and piloting I think was you
know the one that was the predominant
[Music]
skill I guess you could say that helped
me do the job on the space station maybe
it was more like as an engineer because
the space station is not very much it's
not really like an airplane it's more
like a ship maybe that happens to be in
space so you know you're more of a
handyman and the you know the repair guy
I am the spacecraft the engineer times a
scientist so I think you know the
engineer skill was probably more
relevant you talk in your book endurance
about the challenges of long-term
spaceflight the effects on the body
there's the psychological impact of the
isolation you have this particularly
interesting circumstance where you have
a twin brother
who can be compared physically and maybe
we can learn from that about more
specifically what some of the physical
effects are of spending as long in space
as you have what information do you have
so far I've been following how you've
been undergoing all sorts of different
testing to figure out exactly what was
the impact of spending so long in space
what interesting sort of tidbits do you
have so far about the sort of most
important impact of spending that much
time in space well you know science is a
process and science that the government
does is a longer process generally for
an experiment that's conducted onboard
the space station it takes about five
years from you know the conclusion of
the data collection to publication
there's a lot of data analysis generally
they don't have as much time pressure as
if you're a university research or doing
something in the commercial industry so
you know they take their time they have
things peer-reviewed which is normal and
then publish that it takes a while but
you know some of the results I've heard
about you know cognitively you know my
cognitive ability kind of went down
right after I got back from space hmm
maybe like solve complex problems I
think I was probably just due to the
fact that I really didn't feel well for
a while because of the you know the
effects gravity has on ER our physiology
as we come home yeah can you talk about
that maybe in a little bit more detail I
mean we know that it's common that when
astronauts first get back the impact of
coming back to gravity is significant
you spent a year in space so how long
did that last and like how do you
experience it I would say you know
before I felt absolutely back to normal
was probably about eight months Wow you
know the majority of it in the beginning
you get through dizziness the nausea the
flu like symptoms the stiffness the
soreness the rashes and hives I had
where my skin had not touched anything
for so long the
swelling in my legs which was probably
the worst thing yeah that all kind of
dissipates over over time to get back to
your original question though about the
experiments you know one other thing
that was there's a few things that
compared to my brother we're interesting
our microbiome is different and you know
those people that are familiar with
science microbiome is all the bacteria
that lives inside of you generally in
your gut and there's more of them than
there are us we have more bacterial
cells that live inside of us than we
have of our own cells so and a
microbiome has been discovered to be
very important in different various
aspects of our health with disease and I
you know it's more just interesting to
me that mark an eyes microbiome were not
the same which is because a lot of what
kind of microbiome you have has to do
with your diet and particularly where
you travel around the world where you
live what type of you know bacteria
you've been exposed to the other ones
that got a lot of attention was my
telomeres got better our telomeres or
these end caps on our chromosomes that
as we age they get more afraid and
damaged and shorter and that's an
indication of our physical age so the
hypothesis was I would go to space a lot
of radiation stressful environment my
telomeres we get shorter compared to my
brother's but in fact they got better
and longer so you know it doesn't mean
space is like gonna be some Fountain of
Youth or anything it just means that
there's some something going on there
that they need to understand better yeah
often in the Loray I don't know if
you're familiar with longevity
researcher aburrida gray a lot of his
research is focused on the importance of
telomeres and that that seems absolutely
fascinating that the at least in the
early results it seems that what
happened was the opposite of what was
hypothesized you know it's always a good
experiment when your results are the
exact opposite of what you thought would
happen so yeah so
yeah like I said I don't think it's
gonna be a fountain of youth but it's
interesting to see maybe how much
control you can have over your telomeres
with Hill diet and exercise despite the
harsh environment you're living in and
then the the last one that got a lot of
attention was the how 7% of my gene
expression change and as compared to my
brother's actually more than that change
but when we got back still seven percent
of my genes and G your genes for your
listeners are not your pants they're
here your DNA RNA and protein and how
they behave has a lot to do with who we
are and what diseases we get all kinds
of things so gene expression is one of
these pieces of DNA RNA or protein
either turning itself on activating or
deactivating turning themselves off and
they don't know what these genes control
so in some cases this might be a good
thing maybe a gene turned on that would
prevent me from getting some kind of
disease sure or maybe a gene turned on
or off that would cause me to be more
likely to get that so we don't really
know much other than the fact that
there's a you know a physiological
phenomenon going on where that this
environment affects us at a genetic
level when it comes to some of the more
sort of day-to-day things that you
experience on the space station like for
example the the weirdness of the arms
hanging at your sides calluses on your
feet going away when you sleep you don't
have that experience of sort of taking
all the weight off because you're in
zero gravity all the time is that stuff
more impactful psychologically or is it
the physical side because I imagine that
the psychological impact of all those
things every single day for a year would
start to sort of wear on you it's more
the physical it is okay especially with
the carbon
on the space station they have to deal
with it it varies throughout the course
of the day and depending on how the
hardware is working depending on how
many people are on board maybe even how
many animals might be producing carbon
dioxide if you let's see had a lot of
mice and also depending on how the
hardware is working to get rid of it so
you know there are two physical things
about being in space for a long time
that would be great to be able to do to
get rid of them one like I just
mentioned the carbon dioxide the other
one is the fact that all the fluid in
their bodies have in the absence of
gravity just kind of redistribute you
know how our you know wherever our
hearts pushing them yeah well what that
means is when you get the space all of a
sudden your head is swollen
you know the rap song big-headed
astronaut not it's just it's not about
our egos you know that's about like I
think physically your head swells up and
even after a year it never quite goes
back to normal so you feel like you have
this pressure in your head which you do
and it's not pleasant not for I mean
it's it's not something that's you know
over time it gets better it's not
absolutely horrible but it's not great
that's a good place to pause we're
speaking with retired astronaut scott
kelly we will pick it up we'll talk
about his book endurance his time on the
International Space Station and much
more we're continuing our conversation
with retired astronaut scott kelly
veteran of four space flights commanded
the International Space Station on three
expeditions including being a member on
the year-long mission Scott I want to
talk a little bit about the future of
space exploration and space travel more
generally this has become quite
political either for better or worse I
would argue for worse you're we
currently have a situation where there
is more and more debate around should we
be funding organizations like NASA
should the future of space exploration
be led by the government or by private
industry or both can you give me like a
general
of where you see this debate right now
you know I haven't heard much of about
it much of a debate should we fund NASA
I haven't read that NASA is generally a
pretty well supported government agency
that very bipartisan support people
generally like the space program now
they don't necessarily want to spend as
much money on it as NASA would need to
do some of the things we're asked to do
but you know by and large our budget has
continued to increase over you know
since the end of the you know Apollo
program granted we don't we we don't get
as much money as we used to but you know
our budget has been not subject to the
cuts that other government agencies have
had now having said that you know it's
always great to get more money and then
there is this argument or you know this
I wouldn't even go as far as say it's an
argument I mean we are in a partnership
with private industry nASA has given
SpaceX billions of dollars to build
their transportation systems to the
International Space Station NASA as a
part of that SpaceX has been able to
take that money and do some pretty
incredible things
so this government private partnership
which way do you go or flying people in
space you go both ways
you know SpaceX Boeing companies like
that I think will soon be providing
access to low Earth orbit NASA will be
you know developing a transportation
system to go deeper into space now
depending on how much money we give NASA
to do this will depend on what we get
and when we get it and I think probably
at our current level of funding I'm
gonna take a long time you know we're
not going to Mars anytime soon we could
if you wanted to pay for it but you know
I think the public
you know likes to government to use
their money in a you know for the most
part in a you know in a methodical and
reasonable way and you know they're not
willing to cut Nana a check for fifty or
a hundred billion dollars a years so
this is gonna be a slow process but you
know I don't think there's a whole lot
of argument going on about whether we
supply in space and whether NASA is the
better than SpaceX I think at least the
people that are familiar with the
industry know that there's a place for
you know public government-run
spaceflight and also a new place for
privately run companies well you know
along these lines when you hear about a
space force as a way to spend money in
space but not in the way that an
organization like NASA would would
normally be spending money what occurs
to you what what is your thought about
that
well you know the space force idea I
don't even know where they came from
exactly came from the President himself
maybe from some advisors people often
confuse that term with NASA including I
think maybe even the president mention
space words at the same time NASA
doesn't have anything to do with this
space force which doesn't even exist
yeah nor do they want to I mean this is
a government organization that is was
created for peaceful purposes for the
exploration of space
my understanding of space force is
you're basically taking a capability
that the US Air Force already has and
then you're creating this huge
bureaucracy around it to support it
because you're pulling it out of the air
force and somehow this is a good thing
creating a new bureaucracy to arguably
you know
one of the largest bureaucracies in the
world at the Department of Defense so I
you know I don't it doesn't make any
sense to me if it was up to me and
someone asked me hey we want to create a
new branch of the Armed Services I would
say well if we really want to do that
and we think it's necessary I would I
would create the cyber cyber force
before the space force I mean it seems
like that is our bigger immediate threat
than threats in space although we do
have them I mean we do have a there's
always a potential for an arms race in
space and that's something we need to
take very seriously but if we needed a
new you know a military branch clearly I
think cyber would be a money better
spent or do you consider yourself a
political guy and I ask that because
you're very diplomatic in your answers
but it's also very very clear what it is
that you're saying and of course you
know your brother husband of former
democratic congresswoman Gabby Giffords
and has become very active on the gun
violence front I mean do you do you see
yourself as a political person you know
I would like to the problem I have is
that I'm so much of an independent and
you know I really couldn't have any
success you know there are issues that
more in line with the Democrats there's
other issues are more aligned with the
Republicans and unfortunately the way
our political system is is designed you
know especially in Congress with a
gerrymandering you know changing these
political districts to support one party
or you know how people raise money with
you know citizens united where companies
can pay you know unlimited funds to
elect their candidate for a guy like me
kind of in the middle is it's not a
really good spot to have an impact I
think in there in our political system
so you know sometimes I would
like to think of myself as ice
definitely have opinions yeah but
they're not in line with the you know
the mainstream of both of our major
parties you know I think they're things
we could do to fix that if we decided to
if our country ever decided a we want we
want a government that more represents
you know us you know let's get the
corporation's out of it let's even in
some ways get the political parties out
of it a little bit I would like to see
people vote for candidates what versus
you know a party know about the people
you're voting for maybe you know states
need to consider laws where you don't
have the the party the candidates party
on the ballot
yeah in fact there are low there are
municipalities within states that have
done that and it it seems to actually
work pretty well because you can't just
show up and check off whatever party it
is you voted for last time and it'd be
an uphill battle to do it at the state
level but I'm completely on board with
you as far as that goes yeah some people
just Duggal the ruler job because they
think they're a Republican or a Democrat
and they don't really even know you know
it's just like kind of weird identity
politics where they identify with one
group without even really knowing what
that group stands for what that person
stands for yeah so yeah then go back to
your original question I follow politics
I like it it's interesting to me but I
don't think there would ever be a place
for me because you know I'm too much of
a independent and finding lead anchor
maybe last thing I wanted to ask you
about and I've heard astrophysicist Neil
deGrasse Tyson deal with these types of
individuals what is your approach to
those who believe conspiracies like we
never went to the moon there's a Flat
Earth insert whatever right when it
comes to science and that it relates to
your field is there any value to
engaging with those individuals or is
time better spent working on other
things let them let them believe what it
is they want to believe and leave it at
that you know that's a tough question
you know my first inclination is to
laugh
make a joke you know that generally
doesn't help the situation especially if
people really really believe in in these
types of conspiracy theories I think I
think a lot of people don't believe them
and they just do it you know agitate
other people really or yeah I think I
can't imagine those all those people
that go to that Flat Earth conference
really believe the earth is flat what
they do it because it's fun you know
it's like some people believe in aliens
because it's fun to believe in aliens
right you don't actually think that
they're running around in our society in
costumes right hi driver two days ago
definitely seemed to I was trying to
suss out whether he believed it no but I
know what you're saying there's sort of
like an there's there's an escapism
element to it for some people yeah I
think so but there is a risk because you
when you start questioning things that
are scientific back when you can
convince people that some people that
the earth is not flat or there's not
round that it's flat I can convince
people of the earth is not flat pretty
easily but the earth is not round it
then it makes it easier to convince
those same people of other things that
are maybe more risky like climate change
is not real this is not a problem
our earth is not getting warmer and the
streets of Miami are not flooding and we
do not have more storms and more fires
and a an environment that's gonna be
much more challenging and expensive to
live in you know for children so I think
there's that the you know
if you start embracing conspiracy
theories you are more likely to embrace
other ones and some of those could be
dangerous yes so it's sort of like the
the wackier ones become a gateway to the
ones that have serious and sort of like
immediate impact on the human race yeah
especially and especially when it's pee
people that are you know elected to
represent us in government that have
some of these similar beliefs where you
know you have you have a person that is
not a trained scientist does not have a
science background but because of just
their own personal opinion they will
discount what you know 97% of scientists
say about climate change and you know
they'll say well those guys are wrong
and I'm right
because I'm smart not because I'm a
scientist or because I think I'm smart
when maybe I'm really not well said well
said the book is endurance we've been
speaking with the book's author Scott
Kelly who's a retired astronaut was on
numerous expeditions to the
International Space Station including
the year-long mission Scott really
appreciate you taking time to talk to me
today yeah thanks my pleasure enjoyed it